-Let´s talk about
"Thor: Ragnarok."
Now, this movie
already opened overseas
and to amazing reviews, and
people love it, and it´s fun.
-Crazy, yeah.
-It´s insane
how big these movies are.
-Very crazy, yeah.
-And this is the
third time you´ve done it?
-Number 97.
-97th film as Thor.
-Yeah.
-But --
-It feels like --
I mean,
I´m doing my seventh film.
-Yeah.
-Seventh time playing Thor.
-Appearance. ´Cause you show up
in the other ones.
-In the other ones,
briefly, in the background.
-But this one --
[ Laughter ]
But this one, you cut --
Thor cut his hair.
-Cut his hair, yeah.
Look, I´d done it a few times,
this character,
and kind of got very sick
of myself as that character,
and I called up our director
and I said,
"Look, I´m sick of myself,"
and he said, "So am I."
[ Laughter ]
-Who is this guy?
He´s great.
-Taika Waititi.
He´s a New Zealand guy,
who´s one of the greatest
directors out there.
And so we basically decided
just to kind of
reinvent the character
in the world
and do something
completely different,
and a lot of the film
is highly improvised.
It´s a lot more comedy.
It´s a lot more crazy action.
It´s a lot more
kind of unpredictable and --
Yeah, there´s a great sense of
pride, I think, with all of us,
because we did want to do
something different, and we did,
and people responded to it,
and...
-Yeah, ´cause a lot of people,
they probably go,
"Oh, well, Chris can´t --
I don´t know
if he can do comedy,"
but then if you´ve ever seen
"Ghostbusters,"
you crushed in that.
That was so funny. Well done.
-Oh, thanks.
-And then "Saturday Night Live,"
you were fantastic, as well.
-Yeah, that was kind of the --
I did "Saturday Night Live."
I did "Vacation,"
did "Ghostbusters,"
and kind of
was having fun improvising,
and then thought, "God, we could
do more of that in ´Thor´,"
and thankfully,
the Marvel guys said,
"Yeah, go for it,"
and we did.
And I got to say,
laughing for six months,
shooting the movie and mucking
around with your mates
is the best way to go to work,
if you can even call it that.
-Yeah, isn´t it great?
It´s fun.
-It´s wonderful, yeah.
-Well, congrats on this.
I want to show a clip.
Here´s Chris Hemsworth as Thor
in "Thor: Ragnarok."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He is a creature.
What can we say about him?
Well, he´s unique.
There´s none like him.
I feel a special connection
with him.
He´s undefeated.
He´s the reigning...
he´s the defending....
ladies and gentlemen,
I give you...
-Uh-oh.
[ Rumbling, metal creaking ]
-Your incredible...
-[ Roaring ]
Hulk!
-Yes!
[ Crowd silences ]
-I have to get off this planet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Yes!"
-That´s your buddy.
-That´s my buddy.
-The Hulk.
-A friend from work.
-Chris Hemsworth, everybody.